man hat ihn das orakel von omaha genannt
den waisen von der basler und schon in
jungen jahren wusste er das erreicht
werden würde als ich zehn jahre alt war
war mir klar dass mich ein langes leben
habe am ende viel geld haben würde und
hinter seinem volkstümlichen auftreten
verbirgt sich einer der gewieftesten und
härtesten geschäftsmänner amerika jonas
keine 40 milliarden dollar in dem man
mister rogers oder einer der muppets ist
warren geht über leichen wenn es um eine
verhandlung geht er nutzt jeden hebel
dena hat
[Musik]
warren buffett hat die risikoreichen
spekulationen der wall street gegeben
er lebt und arbeitet in omaha wo er 1930
geboren wurde und wo seine besessenheit
von allen finanziellen dingen begann ich
wusste dass ich mich für den rest seines
lebens für aktien interessieren würde
schon als ich acht oder neun war ich
führte tabellen über alle möglichen
aktien
eine tante schenkte mir einen weltall
nach und so lernte ich die
bevölkerungszahlen aller größeren städte
auswendig ich mochte einfach zahlen
nicht nur wirtschaftszahlen
kafitz fähigkeit sich an diese zahlen zu
merken sollte die grundlage für seinen
späteren erfolg sein
großvater hatte einen lebensmittelladen
ich kaufe aber ihm coca cola im
sechserpack für ein quarter und
verkaufte sie für einen fünfer pro stück
verkaufte zeitungen an türen ich hatte
alle möglichen kleinen projekte nicht
alle sehr erfolgreich aber ich machte
von klein auf kerngeschäfte mit
16 schrieb sich buffett an der wharton
school der universität von pennsylvania
ein wo er mit charles peterson zusammen
bunte jeden tag nach dem unterricht
verbrachte ich so viele stunden damit
krieg zu studieren ich nahm die bücher
in die hand und saß da und blätterte
seite für seite
und er konnte in ein paar wochen zwei
oder drei kurse durcharbeiten
er hatte ein fotografisches gedächtnis
ich nicht
buffett entdeckte auch früh seine liebe
zur politik ich war präsident des klubs
der jungen republikaner an der uni von
pennsylvania und kandidierte sogar
einmal als delegierter für die
landeskongress als republikaner
nachdem er das college beendet hatte
machte waffe keinen abschluss an der
columbia business school und kehrte nach
omaha zurück um sein eigenes unternehmen
zu gründen er sagte ich werde eine
gesellschaft gründen und er fragte wirst
du mitmachen ich sagte natürlich will
ich zunächst waren wir nur sieben oder
acht leute und noch weitere investoren
zu überzeugen wurde schon schwieriger
eine verkaufs gespräche waren nicht sehr
effektiv ich war 20 jahre alt so ausgeht
16 und benahm nicht wahrscheinlich wie
ein 12-jähriger ich ging herum und
sprach die leute an die waren immer nett
zu mir aber ich ging zu irgendeinem an
und erklärte ihm all diese fakten und
zahlen warum man aktien kaufen sollte
wenn ich dann mit allem durch war zählte
ich bis 3
und dann sagte der mann was sagt ihr
vater dazu ich hätte ihn hauen können
es war frustrierend buffett wusste dass
er ein besserer verkäufer werden musste
also wandte er sich an den bekannten
selbsthilfe guru dale carnegie ich
musste besser mit menschen kommunizieren
vor allem in gruppen ich wusste einfach
dass sich diese angst vor öffentlichen
auftritten loswerden musste und ich
hatte von diesem dale carnegie kurs
gehört ich habe meiner frau während
dieses kurses einen heiratsantrag
gemacht also direkt auf meine kosten
gekommen
jetzt konnte paffett endlich seine
karriere in gang bringen hingehen er
wählte aktien aus die andere ignorierten
und seine papiere stiegen immer weiter
nach und nach sprach sich in omaha herum
dass der junge mann wusste was er tat
in den ersten fünf jahren in denen
buffett im geschäft war stieg der dow um
74 prozent während barths anlagen um 250
prozent zulegen
1961 im alter von 30 jahren wurde er
millionär
aber das sah man seiner familie nicht an
ihr haus in dem buffett immer noch lebt
sie kaufte er vor über 50 jahren für
32.000 dollar seine kinder gingen alle
auf öffentliche schulen
susi buffett ist das älteste von drei
kindern
wir sind auf eine art aufgewachsen die
wahrscheinlich anders ist als die der
meisten kinder die einen vater haben der
das hat was mein vater hat sie haben
keine autos bekommen als wir 16 waren
wir haben nicht wirklich anders gelebt
als die meisten anderen kinder die wir
kannten
[Musik]
die größte veränderung im buffett
haushalt bestand darin dass warren sich
vom republikanismus seines vaters ab
band
die bürgerrechte hatten den größten
einfluss auf meine einstellung zur
politik keine der beiden parteien hat
sich unbedingt mit ruhm bekleckert er
war die demokraten schienen sich darauf
viel mehr einzustellen als die
republikaner
mit anfang dreißig wollte warren buffett
unternehmen finden an denen er eine
mehrheitsbeteiligung erwerben konnte und
er fand eines 100 meilen entfernt in
beatrice nebraska
remstal war ein unternehmen gemäß
wirklich nicht gut gehen das war im
windmühlen geschäft tätig windmühlen
sind ja heute wieder entkommen aber vor
50 jahren war das kein gutes geschäft
die aktien wurden sehr billig gehandelt
also kaufe ich welche die ehemalige wall
street analystin ellie skoda ist die
autorin von der schneeball grafites
autorisierte lebensgeschichte es war ein
unternehmen das große lagerbestände
aufgebaut hatte dies nicht brauchte und
die belegschaft war viel zu groß das
unternehmen musste einfach verkleinert
werden die staaten der es war sehr klein
und es war der hauptarbeitgeber
100 menschen verloren ihren job und
buffett musste dafür geradestehen was
warren buffett daraus gelernt hat ist
dass er sich nicht mehr in unternehmen
einmischen wollte die arbeits probleme
hatten in denen er leute entlassen
musste in denen er sich persönlich in
das management einmischen musste er
wollte dass jemand anderes das tut auch
was fürs nächste große investition sah
nach einem möglichen misserfolg aus eine
textilfabrik namens berkshire hathaway
deren aktien für 7 dollar und 50 wir
haben einen text hier unternehmen
gekauft das wie jedes andere
textilunternehmen den juden bestimmt war
irgendwann zu verschwinden das war ein
fehler glänzen ist geschäftsführender
gesellschafter von tieto partner
war kein gutes unternehmen sie hatten
keinen wettbewerbsvorteil der es ihnen
ermöglicht eine ausreichende rendite zu
erwirtschaften sie waren zwar in
gewissem maße profitabel aber diese
rentabilität wurde unaufhaltsam kleiner
herausgezogen wurde wurde reinvestiert
die erste große reinvestition die sehr
profitabel war war das
versicherungsgeschäft und das trieb
alles an was berkshire hathaway von da
an tat
ist reporter bei bloomberg news er
verlagerte das unternehmen also von der
textil zur versicherungsbranche zum teil
deswegen weil die branche selbst gewinne
ab war aber auch weil waffe die prämien
die er von seinen versicherungsnehmern
bekam wieder in aktien investieren
konnte
das nennt man float die
versicherungsprämien bringen zinslos
geld einbringen das dann in andere
unternehmen investiert werden da wird
fand auch einen partner der genauso
markt konnte zwar wie er charlie manga
der als anwalt arbeitete als die beiden
sich kennenlernten
als ich ihn kennenlernte erzählte er mir
wie viel besser seine lebensweise sei
und dass sich zu klug sei um in einem so
dünnen geschäft wieder anwaltspraxis zu
arbeiten während ich wie er eine
investitions partnerschaft leiten könnte
und ich brauchte etwa zwei oder drei
jahre um zu erkennen er hatte recht
in den späten 60er jahren erlebte die
wall street einen beispiellosen die
kurse schossen hoch und jeder stürzte
sich in den aktienmarkt aber für buffett
war es an der zeit auszusteigen
ich hatte etwas mehr als 100 millionen
dollar und viele glückliche partner
und die schrieben einen brief ich sagte
ich weiß nicht mehr wie ich dieses spiel
spielen soll die bewertungen sind so
gestiegen dass sich nichts mehr finden
kann ich beendete meine partnerschaft
nicht intuitiv zu sein aber rollen hat
immer gas louis zitiert der sagte sei
gierig wenn andere ängstlich sind so
ängstlich wenn andere gierig sind und
warum wusste dass die party irgendwann
zu ende ist und die blase platzen wird
buffett war 40 jahre alt und über 25
millionen dollar schwer
aber er war unruhig und traf 1973 die
schicksalhafte entscheidung sich in eine
kalifornische bank namens visco
einzukaufen
das problem war es cool befand sich
mitten in einem fusions geschäft mit
einem anderen unternehmen
und dann beschwerte sich das unternehmen
das risko kaufen wollte bei der
börsenaufsichtsbehörde wollen würde
versuchen ihre fusion zu verhindern was
illegal gewesen wäre daraufhin wurde
eine untersuchung eingeleitet
die börsenaufsicht untersuchte jeden
winkel von buffetts geschäft und was sie
sahen alarmierte sie buffett und mangas
investitionen waren ein komplexes
spinnennetz von eigentum und kreuz
beteiligungen wir waren da hineingeraten
weil wir mehrere unternehmen hatten das
ganze sah aus wie eine menge spaghetti
das für irgendeinen bösen zweck gemacht
worden war
wir haben nicht das gefühl dass wir
etwas verbotenes getan hatten aber es
gab viele regeln und die frage ob wir
gegen welche verstoßen hatten
[Musik]
immer wenn man feststellt dass dinge so
verdrahtet sind dass es lange dauert bis
man sie versteht kommt der verdacht auf
dass jemand das vielleicht tut um mit
etwas davon zu kommen
was die ermittler ebenfalls stutzig
machte war die tatsache dass manga und
buffett den aktionären an der westküste
einen höheren preis für ihre aktien
anboten als sie auf dem freien markt
erzielen konnten also kauften wir
einfach weiter bis unser kontingent
erschöpft war und zwar um 2 oder 3
punkte höher als wir mussten das war
zwar sehr eigenwillig aber wir hielten
es für das richtige und die
börsenaufsicht drehte durch
um eine katastrophe abzuwenden wandte
sich buffetts anwalt mit einem
unorthodoxen ab
er sagte sie malz denn auch wenn das in
deinen augen nicht gut aussieht möchte
ich dass du dir den charakter dieser
person an guckst in meiner meinung nach
wird er wahrscheinlich die nummer eins
der finanzdienstleistungsbranche aller
zeiten
ward die appellen hatte erfolg buffetts
unternehmen wurde zu 100.000 dollar
strafe verurteilt aber es wurde keine
anklage gegen buffett erhoben
der aktienkurs von berkshire hathaway
stieg auf 93 dollar
wobei die gewinne vor allem auf das
versicherungsgeschäft zurückzuführen
waren buffett hatte auch anteile an
banken kleider herstellern und süßwaren
vertreten aber bei einem unternehmen war
er besonders leidenschaftlich ich liebe
zeitungen merke ich habe angefangen zu
lesen bis nur sie mein vater brachte sie
mit nach hause ich weiß nicht ob ich
sechs oder sieben oder acht war aber es
war das erste was ich mir schnappte
meine schwestern auch
sein erster zeitungs kauf war ein omaha
wochenblatt namens des an die zeitung
gewandt einen pulitzer-preis eine
seltene auszeichnung für ein kleines
blatt
dann begann er aktien der washington
post company zu kaufen die zeitung war
nach dem watergate skandal finanziell
angeschlagen
nein sagen die 1973 waren die aktien
stark gefallen auch weil die nächsten
regierungen der washington post
sozusagen den krieg erklärt hatte
[Applaus]
das interessante ist als wir diesen
stapel für 20 dollar die aktie kaufen
wenn man die leute die sie uns
verkauften gefragt hätte wie viel das
unternehmen eigentlich wert ist hätten
sie gesagt 100 dollar pro aktie und sie
haben trotzdem verkauft ich bin der
nächsten regierung auf ewig dankbar dass
sie damals den staub aufgewirbelt hat
buffett hatte sich immer von den
führungskräften seines unternehmens
wären behalten exakt
aber das war bei der washington post der
fall ist wo die verlegerin seine
gesellschafts partnerin und vertraute
wurde
sie bei einer branche tätig die mich
fasziniert und zwei verschiedenen partys
in washington ein die sehr interessant
war ich sah teile der welt die ich sonst
nicht gesehen hätte geworden werden
aber während sich basis
gesellschaftlicher kreis erweitert
fühlte sich seine frau susie zu hause
zunehmend isoliert und traf eine
entscheidung sie ließ sich nicht von
warren scheiden wo sondern ging nach san
francisco und cisco um ein neues leben
zu beginnen
ich verstehe warum sie umgezogen ist
mein vater wurde immer berühmter und
meine mutter war so gar nicht der misses
wollen buffett typ ihre beziehung hat
sich nie verändert sie waren total
verliebt haben fünf sechs sieben acht
mal am tag miteinander gesprochen sind
zusammen verreist sie konnte bloß
einfach nicht hier leben
um sicherzustellen dass waren in ihrer
abwesenheit versorgt war wandte sich
susi an ihre freundin astrid nach ein
paar monaten
es ist eher unorthodox eine menge leute
haben sicher darüber geredet und alle
möglichen netten sachen darüber gesagt
wie seltsam das sei aber ich denke mir
weißt du was es geht niemanden was an
was in der beziehung anderer passiert es
hat für die drei funktioniert
funktioniert
dorfes ging in die geschichte ein als er
bei der übernahme der american
broadcasting company durch capital city
half dem bis dahin größten medien aber
sein goldenes händchen reichte nicht aus
als buffett 700 millionen dollar in
soliman brothers investiert dem damals
größten investment einige jahre später
geriet solle man in grosse
schwierigkeiten
gabelte pedro das wurde brenzlig als ich
im august 91 einen anruf bekam man
bedeutete mir an welche probleme auf
mich zukam ein händler namens moschee
hat er einige sehr schlimme dinge auf
dem us staatsanleihenmarkt getan zu
diesem schlimmen dingen illegal dieses
solle mannheim lassen der den
anleihemarkt durch den einsatz nicht
genehmigte konnten in die enge trieb um
den anteil von solon zu erhöhen und die
konkurrenten zu verdrängen neuer
stellvertretender vorsitzender bei
salomon brothers nun er war entsetzt
über das was geschah
mir war klar dass wir gegen das gesetz
verstoßen haben wir hatten uns in die
funktion eines wichtigen marktes
eingemischt und die zentralbank wäre
nicht begeistert
[Musik]
ich erinnere mich lebhaft an wenn man es
auf die titelseite der new york an
schafen mit bild aber ein dummkopf
da wurde meine notlage landesweit
bekannt das war wahrscheinlich einer der
schlimmsten tage meines lebens
[Musik]
an der wall street wird gemunkelt dass
die spitze von solon ihren rücktritt
angeboten hat um einen ausschluss des
unternehmens als haupt händler für
staatsanleihen zu verhindern
good friend unternahm einen letzten
verzweifelten versuch das unternehmen zu
retten indem er in omaha anrief und
buffett bat den chef posten zu
übernehmen
ich halte mich da raus um eine reine
weste zu behalten wir hofften dass ich
das vertrauen der leute gewinnen würde
davon gab es jede menge
die krise verschärfte sich als
finanzminister nicholas brady anordnete
das solle man aus dem anleihegeschäft
aussteigt
es wurde an einem sonntagmorgen bekannt
gegeben dass das us-finanzministerium
uns von der liste der wirklich
akzeptablen leute der primärhändler
gestrichen hatte das wäre der todesstoß
gewesen also musste ich was tun und zwar
bis zum handelsstart in tokio
das war eine nationale katastrophe
gewesen und es sah lange zeit so aus als
würde die regierung einfach sagen zum
teufel mit der sohle monrose buffett
verbrachte den ganzen tag mit
verzweifelten telefonaten nach
washington um die regierung zum rückzug
zu bewegen ich war zu tode erschrocken
und das würde mir wahrscheinlich auch an
viele leute wollten dass wir an diesem
wochenende das geschäft aufgeben er habe
ich wusste nicht was passieren würde
gegen 23 uhr gab minister bray dies
solle man noch eine chance und das
geschäft zu besiegeln borste buffett
persönlich
ich war neun monate und vier tage dort
und das ist kein zufall dass nicht 20
jahre später genau sagen kann wie lange
ich dort war aber es war wichtig das zu
erledigen ich würde niemandem wünschen
was mit der firma passiert ist aber und
eben gewisser weise habe ich viel
gelernt und
buffett trifft sich mit der
finanzgemeinde gibt autogramme sie
lieben ihn der mann mit dem blitz
sauberen image der versucht das chaos
bei soul on brothers zu beseitigen
1993 erreichte der aktienkurs
17.000 dollar
aber keine noch so große weltreise
konnte barfuß gewohnheiten ändern lasst
uns über vonns ernährung sprechen hier
ist das gemuese dass er ist
mais am kolben pommes kartoffelpuffer
und das obst wäre bananen creme torte
erdbeerkuchen
ich glaube das war schon an obst klingt
auch mehrere kirsch kohler am tag ich
habe den mann noch nie in meinem leben
und das ist kein witz ein schluck wasser
trinken sehen niemals
die 90er und 2000er jahre waren die zeit
der größten expansion
das unternehmen holte sich das größte
möbelhaus des landes tor einen führenden
hersteller von wohnmobilen foto bluhm
underwear benjamin moore pains dairy
queen geico in schutz
insgesamt über 70 unternehmen mit
250.000 beschäftigten 1000 m bringt
einige investitionen erschienen
unkonventionell lewis thumm er kaufte
die zeitung seiner heimatstadt den omaha
world
und die eisenbahngesellschaft burlington
northern rock das ist es was warren
buffett immer wieder gemacht hat wenn er
in etwas investiert dann schaut jeder
drauf und sagt ich habe es doch gesehen
warum habe ich das nicht gleich erkannt
in omaha wurde die
jahreshauptversammlung von berkshire
hathaway zu einer pilgerstätte für
zehntausende von aktionären es ist
wirklich erstaunlich das stadion ist
voll und die scheinwerfer sind auf einen
kleinen klapptisch gerichtet an dem zwei
80-jährige sitzen und diese beiden 80
jährigen haben mehr ausdauer als alle
anderen im raum
und freitag bis sonntagabend ist ein
nonstop unterwegs und je länger das
wochenende dauert desto mehr energie hat
er
ich kann es nicht erklären es muss an
den bürgern liegen
in den 2000er jahren war waffe zu sich
milliarden dollar
geld das er an eine stiftung geben
wollte wie seine frau susie leiden
sollte sie
doch 2004 statt sowie an einem
schlaganfall nach einer krebsoperation
es war ein großer schock für uns alle
mein vater ich kann ich erklären wie
sehr er sie geliebt hat und wie sehr er
sich auf sie verlassen hat ich fange an
zu weinen wenn ich darüber rede
wissen sie er wird nie ganz darüber
hinwegkommen keiner von uns wird das
wahrscheinlich sie war wirklich etwas
ganz besonderes
zwei jahre nach dem tod seiner frau
heiratete buffett achtet man bei einer
privaten feier
und gab bekannt dass er den großteil
seines vermögens nicht seinen kindern zu
tun sondern der stiftung von bill und
melinda gates vermacht bill gates ist
seit den frühen 90er jahren einer von
buffetts engsten freund
los es war phänomenal
konnten viel ehrgeiziger an viele dinge
herangehen die wir sonst nicht hätten
tun kann es ist jedes jahr ein
gigantisches geschenk mit dem wer
doppelt so erfolgreich sein können wie
wir es ohne je gewesen wären
[Musik]
buffett für eine berühmte persönlichkeit
und ein brillianter geschäftsmann
als die us amerikanische wirtschaft 2008
in die krise geriet war buffett erneut
der retter vieler finanzinstitute die
unter den schuldenbergen zusammenbrachen
der dow schloss am montag mit einem
minus von mehr als 500 punkten
warren buffett ist ein riesiges
gütesiegel für gute haushaltsführung
nation wenn er geld in eine sache steckt
kann man davon ausgehen dass er klug
genug ist diese investition zu tätigen
weil er glaubt dass er damit eine gute
rendite erzielen wird und das beruhigt
die leute wenn die angst am größten ist
zu den unternehmen die von warren
buffett unterstützt wurden gehört
aber inzwischen ist buffett über 80 und
es bleibt die frage wer wird der
nachfolger dieser finanziert ohne an der
spitze von berkshire
es wurde bereits jemand gefunden aber
sein name noch nicht veröffentlicht been
made public
was buffett jedoch verrät sind die
politischen und wirtschaftlichen
anliegen die ihm am herzen
ich glaube in den letzten jahren hat er
einige sachen gesehen wo er dachte da
nicht den mund aufmachen könnte das
etwas bewirken
was er am lautesten anspricht sind die
ungerechtigkeiten des steuersystems tech
system etwas das als affe triegel
bekannt wurde es gibt alle möglichen
superreichen die normale steuern zahlen
aber es gibt eine kleine gruppe die man
sehr leicht finden kann die sehr
niedrige steuern zahlt mich
eingeschlossen
er schätzt sich glücklich zu diesem
zeitpunkt der geschichte in amerika
geboren worden zu sein
ich glaube er ist einer der
eindrucksvollsten
friedlichsten menschen die ich je
getroffen habe er hat mit dem was er
getan hat viel bewegt und jeder mit dem
er zu tun hatte hat damit geld verdient
und sein leben verbessert
es gibt wirklich niemanden wie bohren
wir sollten uns zurücklehnen und von den
tiefgründigen überlegungen profitieren
die er seit seiner jugend über die
wirtschaft angestellt hat
ich habe einfach jeden tag eine tolle
zahl ich warne ich fange an genau das zu
tun was ich im leben tun